you guys should kiss this room yeah you
guys should kiss no oh come on it would
be so cute this movie hey I saw your
selfie earlier man okay cool deal before
she was all for it
yeah can you take yourself down that
would be a good selfie yeah he's winning
the gamut guys this is [ __ ] up after
you yeah I don't know how to like oh my
moves are too sexual for BuzzFeed all
dicks all dicks out I've just seen it
and I say all dicks cuz I do multiple
yeah
multiple dick so the best approach
mm-hmm I feel like I'm being able to
Adam you doing at me yeah it's just
everybody all time I'm the queen of the
French egg that none of you will ever
hear from me again yeah I did text you
one time and then you responded
literally like seven months later it was
like what holy [ __ ]
what do we got here and you said
yourself intercept no never never doing
a wedding except this you marry me it's
illegal no no but for everyone to watch
no we're gonna just a little okay if
you're using both of us as examples okay
I want you guys to elope but also it was
a lifetime special
you [ __ ] all right well you're trying
to get responses you know yeah you're
trying to get matches so what's the
point of saying no she did right didn't
you do that I mean no she planned it
what are you married if your cousin's
watching
that was totally planned no I mean I was
me I wasn't maid of honor and I planned
your feet by my speech
I won't want it my Wang when she wearing
- then I wind it so that's fair yeah
we're good yeah no you're we're on the
rest of Efron yeah what are you baby
strictly board shorts I'm gonna hold up
all three of these oh yeah these guys
that's good no I'm sticking with my
answer yeah
I just like to acknowledge that we went
away and these guys change so thank you
I think you guys are gonna need that in
the Edit